j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité
vous le savez avec cette question les
voyages en avion seront-ils bientôt de
nouveau réservés aux plus riches c'est
pour éviter ce retour en arrière que le
secteur aérien veut se décarboner est-ce
vraiment possible avant d'en débattre
premier tour d'horizon des innovations
avec ce reportage d'Audrey plus tard
[Musique]
ces images semblent à nous dire
un petit avion qui relie l'Allemagne à
la France pourtant ce vol est
exceptionnel c'est la toute première
fois qu'un appareil s'envole avec 97% de
biocarburant à base de sucre dans ces
réservoirs une promesse pour l'avenir
qui se joue d'abord ici dans les
fermenteurs de ce laboratoire
du sucre on a mis nos bactéries
génétiquement modifiées et la magie
s'opère et l'avantage de notre
technologie c'est que l'isobutène la
molécule clé que l'on produit et qui
peut infiner finir dans les moteurs
d'avion elle s'extrait spontanément de
ce milieu de fermentation parce que
c'est un gaz l'idée bien évidemment
c'est de n'être pas du tout en
compétition avec les ressources
alimentaires donc on a travaillé avec
des sucres issus des résidus de
l'agriculture ou de l'industrie
forestière la paille de blé par exemple
ou les copeaux de bois peuvent être
également convertis en sucre ce
biocarburant pourrait remplacer de
moitié le kérosène d'un appareil sans
avoir à en changer le moteur des
certifications sont d'ailleurs bien
avancés mais pour cela il faut à tout
prix monter en puissance pour faire
baisser les coûts de production et les
rapprocher du prix du fossile le coût
des solutions qui empruntent au
biocarburant aux autres solutions sera
toujours plus élevée que le coût du
kérosène fossiles donc il faut qu'il y
ait des incitations volontaires de la
part des États point positif pour le
secteur l'Union européenne demande que 6
% de biocarburant soit intégrés au
kérosène fossiles d'ici 2030 au lieu de
0,1 actuellement de quoi doper peut-être
les investissements à Blagnac on planche
sur une autre solution qui pourrait
arriver très vite sur le marché français
en 2026 ici on transforme des avions
classiques en avion à hydrogène liquide
grâce à ces modules l'intégration des
modules qui contiennent l'hydrogène se
fera à l'arrière de l'avion on met deux
modules par avion là vous avez ici une
chaîne propulsive existante elle sera
remplacée par une chaîne propulsive qui
sera complètement électrique avec donc
les piles à combustibles et une
motorisation électrique qui ne n'émettra
donc que de l'eau évidemment ça coûte un
peu d'argent mais on est à peu près sur
les mêmes tarifs qu'une remotorisation
d'un avion donc si vous voulez remplacer
vos moteurs vous pouvez vous poser la
question par exemple de est-ce qu'il
vaudrait mieux pas que je remplace par
une solution verte et ça c'est vraiment
l'objectif tout va vite car on utilise
les modules par exemple sont calqués sur
ces conteneurs à bagages et pas besoin
d'adapter les aéroports c'est ce qui a
séduit la compagnie Amélia pour ses vols
régionaux même s'il faut composer avec
14 places en moins dans la vie c'est une
taille qui fonctionne bien effectivement
quand on veut faire plusieurs
allers-retours dans la journée ça permet
aux entreprises aux hommes d'affaires de
faire des allers-retours sur un de jour
plutôt que d'avoir uniquement un vol le
lundi un vol le vendredi avec des avions
plus gros on a un vrai intérêt puisque
on utilise on réutilise des avions qui
qui ont encore du potentiel
on les modifie et on se retrouve avec
une solution de fait 0 émissions le seul
problème reste le prix 10 euros pour un
litre d'hydrogène liquide vert contre un
euro pour le kérosène et le manque
d'incitation aussi aujourd'hui quand on
achète une voiture électrique on a le
droit à bonus écologique quand on veut
mettre des panneaux solaires on a le
droit du crédit d'impôt quand on achète
un avion hydrogène on a pas d'aide
ce qui fait qu'effectivement c'est un
investissement encore plus important
pour les opérateurs les compagnies sont
pourtant le Chesnoy indispensable pour
que l'aviation prenne son virage vers un
horizon plus vert
et pour débattre de l'avenir du
transport aérien j'accueille Béatrice
Jarrige bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes chef
de projet mobilité longue distance au
shift project bonsoir bienvenue à vous
Pascal de isaïir bonsoir bienvenue bons
directeur général de Corsair et le
président de la Fédération nationale de
l'aérien et de ses métiers
Mireille bonsoir bienvenue à vous
professeur de sciences économiques à
l'université parisien Panthéon Sorbonne
économiste de l'environnement Mathieu
croissanto est resté à mes côtés je
commence avec un chiffre on va dire
général l'aviation qui représente un peu
moins de 3% des missions globales de
carbone de CO2 est-ce que c'est le mode
de transport le plus polluant Béatrice
Jarry celui qui elle met le plus de gaz
à effet de serre
alors celui qui émet le plus de gaz à
effet de serre par kilomètre parcouru
par voyageur si on se réfère aux
analyses en tout cas qu'on peut mener en
France sur la mobilité de longue
distance oui effectivement l'avion est
un peu devant la voiture en termes de
démission au kilomètre parcours et donc
de missions de gaz à effet de serre de
consommation de carburant fossile et des
missions de gaz à effet devant la
voiture pas très loin devant la voiture
ça déjà c'est une première info
intéressante oui c'est pas extrêmement
loin devant la voiture c'est en revanche
la voiture thermique tout à fait la
voiture thermique le gap important c'est
surtout avec le train train électrique
où il y a un écart très important entre
avions et voitures d'une part et train
d'autre part parce qu'elle les ayant on
l'a vu dans le reportage le le secteur
de l'aviation voilà il y a des
alternatives il y a de l'innovation
c'est en train de se mettre en place
trouver des alternatives au kérosène ce
virage il date de quand et à quel point
il est poussé voilà par la
réglementation aussi expliquez-nous
alors écoutez le secteur aérien est très
engagé puisque vous savez que nous
sommes le premier secteur à avoir
élaboré notre feuille de bicarbonation
feuille de route pour la bicarbonation
que nous avons remis au pouvoir public
le 14 février donc c'est très récent et
donc c'est un travail collectif entre
les constructeurs les motoristes les
aéroports les énergéticiens parce que
quand on parle de carburant durable les
énergéticiens sont indispensables et
cette feuille de route elle a identifié
très clairement les principaux leviers
pour mener à ces décarbonations qu'un
objectif zéro émission net en 2050 les
moyennes nécessaires on achiffrer les
périodes intermédiaires avec des des
paliers en quelque sorte de réduction
des émissions les quantités de biomasse
et d'électricité nécessaire donc ce que
je crois c'est qu'on a une feuille de
route extrêmement claire et donc tout le
secteur aérien est mobilisé pour
l'atteindre cette feuille de route c'est
la réglementation qui vous y pousse et
voilà un engagement c'est la certitude
que si vous le faites pas c'est pas que
la réclamation on a une responsabilité
sociale et environnementale donc je
pense que la préservation de la planète
c'est un objectif de être partagé par
tous et donc y compris par le transport
arrière donc on est tout à fait la
conscience que nous devons apporter
notre pierre à l'édifice et notre
contribution Mireille sur l'insuline je
voudrais qu'on parle de fiscalité tiens
pour pour vous donner la parole une
première fois aujourd'hui à l'instant T
même s'il y a des efforts qui sont faits
l'aviation reste polluante et que que
dit la fiscalité est-ce qu'elle lui est
favorable trop favorable d'après vous la
fiscalité est assez favorable à
l'aviation
d'abord il a souvent été dit que le
kérosène n'est pas taxé et ça c'est
c'est quand même un véritable problème
parce que le contenu en carbone de ce
carburant n'est pas taxé alors que le
contenu en carbone d'autres utilisations
des énergies fossiles et
donc ça c'est un vrai problème les
billets d'avion sont taxés lorsque ce
sont des des vols domestiques sont accès
à 10% comme les billets de train mais
après tout on pourrait aussi envisager
que pour des raisons environnementales
ont un taux de TVA supérieur par exemple
pourquoi pas à 20%
l'aviation alors il y a un élément qui
n'est pas de la fiscalité rigoureusement
mais qui est l'intégration du du trafic
aérien dans le marché européen de quota
de carbone cette intégration est en fait
elle est effective avec une distribution
de quotas qui est en grande partie
gratuite
pollueur qui est soumis à ce à ce marché
doit pouvoir produire
l'autorisation
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il émet donc une tonne
une tonne de de carbone le donc le
trafic aérien a été intégré dans ce dans
ce marché mais jusqu'à présent et
jusqu'en 2023 compris les quotas lui
sont distribués en très grande partie de
façon gratuite d'accord alors ça veut
dire oui
ça veut dire que la contrainte existe
mais elle est très relative mais c'est
quotas vont être ensuite vendus aux
enchères progressivement je d'ici trois
ans cette cette gratuité aura disparu le
plus simple et le plus évident
c'est-à-dire la question de la taxation
du du kérosène Pascal de Isaia pourquoi
pourquoi est-il pas taxé ou moins taxé
et quel serait l'effet d'une taxation
c'est la convention de Montréal
l'organisation de la relation civile
internationale qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
dans tous les accords et un bilatéraux
vous avez prévu la non taxation du
kérosène donc revenir sur cette mesure
ça nécessiterait bien passé de réviser
tous les accords avec les autres pays
chaque pays fait on pourrait faire sa
loi sinon on pourrait avoir les
approvisionnements
du secteur aérien il soit pris à
l'échelle planétaire et certainement pas
les chaînes nationales ou même européens
c'est vrai que dans le cas de la
mondialisation d'incendie que l'Europe
c'est un peu l'idiot du village
mondialisation l'idiot du village dans
le transport rien pour faire attention à
ce qu'on appelle les fuites de carbone
qui vont que c'est très bien de vouloir
pénaliser le secteur aérien et
aronautique français et européen mais si
les Chinois le font pas les Indiens les
Turcs les catharis etc ça nuira à la
compétitivité au dynamisme de cette
industrie aérienne et aéronautique voilà
par ailleurs je corrige un peu vos
propos madame parce que vous parlez de
faits qualité environnementale mais
enfin le transport aérien le secteur
aérien c'est un peu la vache chalet en
tout cas dans notre pays parce qu'en
fait on croule sous les taxes et les
redevances c'est quand même un secteur
qui distributeur net au budget de l'État
c'est un secteur qui finance lui-même
toutes ces infrastructures et donc on a
énormément de taxes voilà et par
ailleurs on pourrait dire une note de
nos demandes c'est que les taxations sur
l'aérien pour l'environnemental soit
fléchés vers la décarbonation du secteur
aérien ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas
vous répondre en fait
la question de la de la taxation
environnementale c'est pas juste une
question de savoir si ça se surimpose à
d'autres taxes qui sont prélevés pour
d'autres raisons c'est le fait que il
faut que le juste prix du trafic aérien
soit payé par celui qui l'utilise et
actuellement ça n'est pas le cas ça
n'est pas le cas parce que ce prix
n'intègre pas les dommages qui sont qui
sont qui sont causés au climat en raison
de en raison des voyages aériens donc
on a parlé enfin votre reportage faisait
mention de solutions technologiques qui
sont à rechercher bien sûr mais ce ne
seront que des pierres à l'é c'est un
mot qui a été prononcé tout à l'heure ce
ne seront que des pierres à l'édifice et
on ne parviendra pas à zéro émission
nette dans les délais prévus si on ne
maîtrise pas aussi la demande et
maîtriser la demande il faut le levier
de la fiscalité pour maîtriser la
demande et le levier de l'innovation
pour faire évoluer la technologie on va
continuer de d'avancer sur sur ce débat
et vous aurez l'occasion dans dans
reparler je voudrais que vous me disiez
un mot vraiment pour bien poser on
essaie de de faire un peu de pédagogie
Béatrice Jarry ce qui s'est passé la
réglementation européenne elle est en
train de changer on va parler des
biocarburants maintenant est en train de
changer avec le le quoi des seuils de
biocarburant autorisés plus important
dans les avions c'est ça qui est en
train de se passer oui si vous me
laissez une seconde peut-être pour
réagir sur le le mot taxe qui est
employé dans l'aérien en général il y a
beaucoup de thèmes d'abord
s'appelle une redevance
d'infrastructures dans le secteur
ferroviaire il y a des redevances on
appelle ça des péages quand on prend une
autoroute on paye aussi un péage les
acteurs de l'aérien appellent taxe des
choses qui sont souvent des redevances
donc c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait
exact de dire qu'ils sont très taxés ils
payent ils payent des redevances pour
l'usage des infrastructures qui leur
sont propres alors sur sur la nouvelle
réglementation plus de biocarburant dans
les avions c'est ce qui est en train de
suivre
donc le green dit l'Européen c'est c'est
de plus en plus de de biocarburants
incorporés
au fioul actuel puisque on peut mettre
dans le kérosène dans les moteurs aux
normes actuelles une proportion allant
jusqu'à 50% de ses carburants de
nouvelle génération donc c'est 2% pour
2025 et comme cela était annoncé tout à
l'heure c'est 6% pour 2030
progressivement l'ambition de la
Commission européenne
jusque
50% de du carburant d'un avion ou ces 2
% j'ai pas compris
du moteur c'est d'accepter jusqu'à 50 %
donc moitié-moitié de là c'est ce que
vous voilà et pour l'instant on en est à
pour l'instant on en est à 0,1% été
évoqué tout à l'heure et on a 2% en
cible pour
2025 ou 26 le monsieur donc c'est de 25
2025 et 2036% donc on est encore très en
de ça de ce que la technique permet mais
le coût le coût de ces carburants est
très élevé donc c'est pas le mouvement
spontané d'une compagnie aérienne de les
utiliser massivement alors on va
détailler cette ces enjeux des
biocarburants avec Jonathan du priez
parce qu'il y avait qui se tenait cette
semaine au Sénat sur ce thème la
directrice générale d'Air France
rebonsoir je l'attends directrice
générale de la France qui était
auditionné je crois que c'était hier les
compagnies aériennes elles s'intéresse
de plus en plus au bio carburant est-ce
qu'on peut parler pour autant de
solutions miracle alors miracle
peut-être pas Thomas ce serait peut-être
un peu abusé mais c'est la solution en
tout cas qui semble être la plus
prometteuse à court terme pour ce
conformer à la réglementation européenne
dont vous venez de parler les
biocarburants pour simplement pour
rappeler à noter les spectateurs ce sont
des combustibles qui sont issus de
déchets agricoles forestiers de l'huile
de cuisson
usagée ou encore pourquoi pas des
graisses animales il présente plusieurs
avantages déjà de réduire entre 50 et
90% des émissions de CO2 par rapport au
kérosène classique et autre point fort
vous l'avez effleuré aussi c'est que
c'est biocarburant il fonctionne avec
des moteurs d'avion déjà existants
jusqu'à une certaine limite mais en tout
cas les compagnies aériennes et bien
elle mise tout sur ses carburants qu'on
appelle dans le jargon le SAF en anglais
comme le soulignait hier écoutait la
directrice générale d'Air France
les carburants durable sont la clé il
représente je dirais dans toutes les
trajectoires de décarbonation qui ont pu
être travaillées à eux seuls plus de 50%
de l'effort de décarbonation du secteur
aérien français à l'horizon 2050 donc ce
ne sont pas un levier transitoire c'est
vraiment une solution de long terme qui
s'étendra à notre avis sauf innovation
rupture majeure mais qu'on ne voit pas à
ce stade bien au-delà de l'horizon de
2050 alors l'un des enjeux majeurs pour
les compagnies aériennes c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de volume de carburant
voilà les compagnies aériennes elles
essayent maintenant de sécuriser ses
approvisionnements en témoigne le
contrat qu'Air France KLM a signé avec
Total énergie pour la fourniture de 800
000 tonnes de biocarburant sur les 10
prochaines années et Air France aussi a
été obligé de diversifier son
approvisionnement avec le leader mondial
des biocarburants qui est une entreprise
finlandaise ou encore aux États-Unis
faute de filière aussi suffisamment
structurée et productive en France donc
l'offre globalement est assez limité et
les prix restent très élevés pour ces
biocarburants en 4 à 8 fois supérieur
qu'un combustible fossile traditionnel
et donc les compagnies aériennes elles
sont dans l'obligation de d'augmenter
peu à peu vous le disiez c'est taux de
biocarburant dans leurs avions
conformément à la réglementation et donc
ça aussi un risque c'est que ça pourra à
terme faire supporter de nouveaux coups
au passager écoutez ce qu'on disait la
directrice générale d'Air France si on
prend un exemple le plus classique un
vol aller-retour entre Paris et New York
avec une incorporation de 20% de SAF
aujourd'hui si on applique ce qui nous
est facturé pour le SAF en France donc
autour de 5000 euros la tonne le surcoût
pour un passager pour le billet
aller-retour serait de 175 euros on ne
dit pas que c'est un surcoût
insupportable on dit simplement que
c'est pas quelque chose d'anecdotique et
que les prix ne seront pas élastiques je
dirais pour permettre de d'incorporer ça
sans aucune voilà en tout cas c'est une
problématique que le gouvernement prend
en considération il devrait y avoir des
annonces sur un plan de structuration de
la filière biocarburant au salon du
Bourget qui se tiendra fin juin voilà et
vous avez aussi c'est une filière vous
en parliez qui est pleine d'avenir
porteuse d'espoir mais qui reste en fait
très très largement sous exploité encore
puisque en fait c'est mieux carburant ne
représente que 0,1% de la consommation
totale des combustibles aviation merci
Jonathan Pascal de isagui j'espère que
vous avez retrouvé votre voix moi aussi
il y a pas de souci est-ce que est-ce
que tu as chez Corsair parce que vous
êtes également le prix en corsaire vous
faites déjà voler vos avions avec un peu
de biocarburant ça fait partie des
options que vous avez en 2022 le quota
était de 1%. le problème c'est que sur
l'aéroport d'Orly il n'y a pas de
carburant donc en fait on paye une taxe
qui s'appelle la thyruire que vous
connaissez mais en fait il n'y a pas la
disponibilité donc le problème c'est que
nous on fait énormément de pression sur
les pouvoirs publics pour qu'il y ait
une véritable filière de production qui
n'existe pas parce que 1% 2% 5% en face
il faut mettre la production donc pour
nous c'est également un gage si vous
voulez d'indépendance énergétique de
souveraineté nationale et ça sera une
filière créatrice d'emploi mais on ne
pourra pas y parvenir sans une
implication forte des énergéticiens
c'est pour ça je lui ai dit on travaille
avec tout à l'énergie là notamment onji
et le et le deuxième sujet c'est que
aujourd'hui donc on n'a pas la
disponibilité et les prix sont très
élevés ils sont de 4 à 8 fois parce que
c'est plus cher combustible fossiles
donc nous demandons aussi au pouvoir
public des mécanismes d'incitation
fiscale comme si comme cela se fait aux
États-Unis dans le cadre de l'Iran donc
l'environnement
a décidé un plan massif de soutien de
subventionnement pour les carburants
durables parce que comme vous l'avez dit
Madame effectivement c'est le premier
levier parce que dès aujourd'hui avec
les moteurs actuels au jour
d'aujourd'hui on peut intégrer jusqu'à
50% de carburant durable il y a pas
besoin de changer de moteur
de 50 % ou les motoristes si vous voulez
sont en train de travailler sur des
moteurs qui pourront aller et jusqu'à
l'intégration de 100%. mais aujourd'hui
les carburants durables permettent une
réduction des émissions de carbone de
80%. donc c'est pour ça que nous disons
c'est le premier levier devant la
modernisation et de renouvellement des
flottes parce que la modernisation est
le renouvellement des flottes ont un
impact aussi par ces varia des
améliorations technologiques mais vous
doutez bien que le processus de
modernisation d'une flotte et de
remplacement prend beaucoup de temps
alors que les carburants durable d'ores
et déjà si ce carburant était disponible
à des coûts compétitifs nous pourrions
intégrer 50% donc ça sera un impact
extrêmement favorable alors donc vous
attendez on l'a bien compris un coup de
pouce de l'état des pouvoirs publics et
on va justement écouter le délégué
chargé des transports Clément Beaune qui
était lui aussi auditionné au Sénat
c'était au mois d'octobre dernier alors
il voit deux leviers pour la
décarbonation à l'écoute d'abord avoir
des moteurs plus économe c'est pas de la
science-fiction j'étais l'autre jour
dans le centre de recherche inauguré
centre de recherche de
safran nous avons des générations de
moteurs qui d'une génération à l'autre
en l'espace d'une décennie peuvent
baisser leur consommation de carburant
de 20% dans la consommation totale de la
viande de 20%. les carburants propres
sont aussi évidemment une des solutions
majeures
et plus globalement les solutions
propres pour l'aviation avec des degrés
de maturité vous le savez mieux que moi
très différents sur l'hydrogène sur
l'électrique peut-être pour les petits
mais sans doute pas pour les gros avions
à court terme et donc les carburants bio
ou de synthèse peuvent être une son à
mon avis la priorité aujourd'hui pour
baisser avec la consommation des moteurs
la consommation générale
Béatrice Jarrige si on reste sur ces
biocarburants
comment ils sont produits il faut il
faut de l'électricité pour les produire
si on fait le bilan carbone de ce de ce
carburant qui pourrait remplacer le
kérosène oui c'est sans doute pour ça
que ça va rester
ces carburants sont chers actuellement
c'était intéressant d'entendre aussi des
industriels qui disaient c'est
carburants vont rester cher parce que
les techniques de production sont très
consommatrices d'électricité notamment
donc il y a différents types de
carburants il y en a qui sont fabriqués
à partir de la biomasse d'autres
d'autres techniques de production mais
toutes les techniques sont
intrinsèquement
consommatrices de d'énergie et de
matière rares puisque sur la biomasse
par exemple on sait que le gisement est
pas extensible à l'infini donc ça pose
un problème de de bouclage en termes de
de prélèvement de ressources qui peuvent
être utiles à d'autres secteurs de
l'économie donc l'importance de faire un
bouclage en offre et en demande de ce
que peut être le le fonctionnement de
l'économie française pas seulement le
secteur des transports et encore moins
seulement juste l'aérien pour comprendre
si la piste d'une extension de de ces
techniques
l'ensemble du trafic aérien tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui voire plus important
puisqu'il est il était sur une tendance
de hausse significative depuis des
années est-ce que c'est tenable ou pas
c'est à dire que même avec ce carburant
là qui est le plus avancé le plus mature
vous nous dites attention peut-être que
que c'est une fausse bonne idée si
j'essaie de bien comprendre ce que ce
que vous nous dites oui c'est ça c'est
ça c'est les calculs qu'on a fait au
chiffre projet là-dessus dans le cadre
du plan de transformation de l'économie
française on voit qu'on peut pas faire
l'économie de d'un effort de sobriété
comme on veut
parce que imaginez étendre ces
techniques à l'échelle du trafic actuel
ça passe pas ça ne marche pas ou alors
il faut vraiment mettre à la diète
d'autres secteurs de l'économie
l'industrie l'agriculture voilà donc il
y a des choix publics à faire mais
je vais vous redonner la parole
évidemment parce qu'elle disait parce
que ça vous fait réagir à un chiffre le
gouvernement qui promet 435 millions
d'euros 435 millions d'euros pour la
transition écologique du transport
aérien bon on va voir on n'a pas encore
le détail vers quelle technologie vers
quelles innovations cet argent pourra
être être donné mais vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée de sobriété
c'est-à-dire que la technologie ne va
pas pouvoir tout solutionner c'est ce
que vous nous dites vous aussi
absolument si on réfléchit aux deux
techniques aux deux technologies qui ont
été évoquées que ce soit la production
d'hydrogène ou la production de
biocarburant ça repose sur un besoin en
électricité qui est énorme et donc comme
l'a dit Madame ses besoins d'électricité
soit on trouve le moyen de les
satisfaire et à court terme c'est quand
même assez compliqué enfin à court moyen
terme c'est c'est très compliqué soit on
trouve le moyen de de
s'en passer et par conséquent ça va de
pair avec ce que j'ai tendance à pousser
plutôt que de subventionner des
technologies même si des coups de pouce
peuvent être intéressants mais avec une
filière qui se crée autant que autant
que la France soit bien placé pour pour
cette filière plutôt qu'on aille acheter
les biocarburants ailleurs
j'ai quand même un signal d'alarme à
lancer les les subventions devraient
dans l'absolu être
versé de telle façon qu'elle n'exerce
pas de verrouillage technologiques
lorsqu'on choisit de subventionner une
filière c'est au dépenses d'autres et on
risque d'empêcher l'émergence d'autres
d'autres technologies qui éventuellement
pourraient être plus avantageuse et donc
il faut faire très attention je pense
qu'il faut il faut par exemple
subventionner en fonction de de la
performance attendue et pas forcément
subventionnée suivant un type de
technologie c'est à dire c'est pas
forcément au gouvernement de faire un
choix entre les techniques
imposée
totalement une partie j'ai une question
c'est quoi sobriété ça veut dire
prendre l'avion une fois par an une fois
tous les 10 ans ne plus prendre l'avion
c'est très difficile à chiffrer ce que
c'est que sobriété c'est important de
dire c'est un comportement plus général
la sobrie la sobriété c'est
éviter des des
comportements de consommation qui sont
en excès c'est-à-dire c'est satisfaire
des besoins mais mais une fois que ces
besoins sont satisfaits ne pas aller
au-delà
que nous on est on fait partie d'une
génération qui a eu la chance de prendre
l'avion et puis découvrir des pays
étrangers
et ça veut dire que la génération qui
vient qui n'a peut-être pas encore
voyagé on va dire les ne voyagera jamais
à l'étranger en avion je pense pas et
en revanche prendre l'avion pour aller
passer un week-end quelque part c'est un
excès ça c'est intéressant on va
continuer d'essayer de définir cette
notion de sobriété et je vais vous
donner la parole aux uns et aux autres
là-dessus mais je vous propose un
témoignage qui va certainement dans
votre intéressant c'est celui du
chercheur climatologue François Marie
Bréon c'était il y a quelques années il
se posait la question des vols
intérieurs français peut-être qu'on
pourrait dire mais il y a plus de il y a
plus d'avions pour à l'intérieur du pays
on pourrait décider que il y a plus de
Paris Toulouse en avion où il y a plus
de Paris Nice en avion ou des choses
comme ça et qui obligerait les gens à
prendre à prendre le train alors ça
c'était 2018 on a ressorti un une
intervention assez ancienne depuis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il y a eu par
exemple la loi climat et résilience qui
a été votée en 2021 qui interdit les
vols intérieurs en France quand il
existe une alternative par le train en
moins de deux heures trente alors cette
cette loi a été suspendue le temps d'une
enquête de la Commission européenne à la
suite d'une plainte du secteur aérien et
elle est entrée en vigueur pour de bon
on va dire décrets d'application ce
mardi on est en pleine actualité Pascal
de Isaia vous avez quoi le secteur
aérien a tenté de freiner cette cette
mesure qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette interdiction finalement de de vol
on va dire courte courte distance en
France
écoutez on n'est pas pour les
interdictions parce qu'on n'est pas pour
les politiques de décroissance ou les
politiques malthusiennes parce que nous
il y a un élément sur lequel nous
insistons beaucoup un c'est qu'on a une
feuille de route de bicarbonation on a
des moyens parce que quand vous parlez
effectivement vous êtes tout à fait
raison que la quantité de biomasse sera
limitée en fait les chercheurs
travaillent sur du I fioul donc purement
chimique et donc ça ne sera pas
dépendant des quantités de biomasse donc
non nous on considère qu'effectivement
nos leviers existent il vaut mieux les
mettre en application deuxièmement le
coût de la décarbonation va de toute
façon faire monter le coût du transport
aérien et le prix des billets d'avion
mais ça c'est valable pour toute la
société et tous les secteurs économiques
la décarbonation ça va être quelque
chose de d'inflationniste donc il y aura
une différenciation par le prix du
billet il y aura des gens qui pouvaient
voyager
nous si vous voulez c'est à la poursuite
de la démocratisation du
demande donc c'est dans le sens de ce
que souhaite madame
mais le problème c'est qu'on ne voudrait
pas qu'on en revienne à l'origine du
transport il y a qui était réservé à une
élite parce qu'en fait si vous laissez
ce à quoi on risque de parvenir voilà et
donc mais c'est un vrai débat est-ce
qu'on peut atteindre je repose la
question est-ce qu'on peut atteindre et
ça reprend les arguments qu'on avait de
ce côté de la table est-ce qu'on peut
atteindre ces objectifs ambitieux de
décarbonation sans un changement de
comportement c'est à dire sans arrêter
ou freiner cette démocratisation mais je
vais être très très honnête je suis
d'accord qu'il y a des comportements
effectivement allez passer un week-end à
Prague après à Budapest ensuite aux
Canaries etc donc mais là je pense que
c'est aux citoyen aussi de de s'auto
réguler c'est à dire que je je me méfie
des interdictions parce que sur quels
critères alors on va dire effectivement
vous allez limiter le nombre de
voyageurs aériens sur quelle base sur
quels critères moi par exemple j'ai des
serres beaucoup les départements
d'outre-mer allez expliquer à nos
compatriotes ultra-marins qui sont
reliés que par l'avion parce que on
parle du train sur les courtes distances
mais sur le long courrier il y a pas
d'alternative allez leur expliquer alors
qu'il y a des communautés très
importantes qui font leurs études ils
vont se faire soigner ils vont faire
leur formation
ça va être très compliqué je desserre
beaucoup l'Afrique à l'expliquer au pays
d'Afrique qui ont besoin pour le
développement économique et social pour
leur désenclamment des liaisons
aériennes qu'il faut limiter ça va être
très très compliqué donc je je ne suis
pas pour les mesures coercitives nous
nous sommes pas pour les mesures
coercitives bon vous vous pensez que la
technologie les innovations vont
permettre d'atteindre les objectifs on a
bien compris
de la science de vision qui qui se pose
c'est assez passionnant Béatrice Jarry
je crois que c'est 5 milliards de
passagers au niveau mondial on est
revenu à peu près au niveau de 2019
est-ce que c'est possible de
m'attend à votre mais de garder un tel
flux de transport aérien et et de faire
baisser le bilan carbone du secteur
non c'est pas possible de garder un tel
flux faire baisser le bilan en carbone
du secteur avec un tel fluide mais c'est
pas soutenable
c'est ça ce que vous nous dites on peut
en utilisant énormément d'électricité
des carbonées des carbonées
l'aérien mais encore faut-il être
capable de produire cette électricité or
au minimum quand on fait l'exercice en
France et en se projetant à 2050 qui
n'est pas si loin que ça même en étant
volontariste sur le la relance d'un
programme de nucléaire même en étant
volontariste sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables éolien et solaire
on bute assez vite sur une une
contrainte de capacité à la produire
cette électricité donc c'est là que le
bât blesse alors j'ai essayé on peut
quand même faire un pari Bordeaux en
avion mais à condition de partir de
Charles de Gaulle de Charles de Gaulle
alors là on a aussi on a un peu on se
je sais pas comment dire on s'adapte
avec avec
la différence
régulier pour faire la liaison entre la
gare TGV de Roissy et Bordeaux c'est ça
l'argument consiste à dire on a le droit
de c'est parce que la distance entre
entre Paris et
l'aéroport a été a été ajouté mais ce
qui est très important c'est que dans le
décret d'application il n'y a que trois
liaisons finalement qui sont interdites
Paris Bordeaux
à deux d'entre elles à la demande du
gouvernement en 2020 et a renonce avait
renoncé à la troisième il y a quelques
temps donc donc de toute façon il y a
pas plus enfin c'est pas plus coercitif
entre guillemets
on va ouvrir un autre thème qui est
beaucoup plus pointu mais quand même
très symbolique tiens je vous propose
quelques images c'est hier plusieurs
dizaines d'activistes du climat qui sont
introduits de force dans le plus grand
salon européen de la vente de jet on est
à Genève forcément et les autorités
aéroportuaires ont dû interrompre
brièvement le trafic aérien Mathieu
cette question des jets privés c'est
devenu une bataille politique oui et au
fond c'est ça a démarré l'été dernier et
c'est une querelle très française qui
met le idéologie symbole et raccourci de
part et d'autre de l'échiquier je parle
du débat dans la classe politique
française ça commence par un coup de
gueule l'été dernier celui de Julien
Bayou qui était alors secrétaire
national des Verts et qui annonce en
août 2022 vous souvenez vouloir bannir
les jets privés alors pour le député de
Paris qui est excédé par les sauts de
puces estivaux des milliardaires qu'on
pouvait suivre d'ailleurs à l'époque on
peut toujours suivre d'ailleurs sur sur
des comptes Twitter c'est l'occasion de
faire d'une pierre deux coups en fait
d'abord pour fendre les élites
capitalistes dans ce qu'elles ont de
plus caricatural et puis surtout ça sur
fond de évidemment de lutte contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
le symbole est trop beau pour s'en
priver en un mois calcule bien Bayou le
jeu jet de l'empereur du luxe Bernard
Arnault première fortune mondiale à EMI
autant qu'un Français moyen en 17 ans
donc un mois 17 ans la polémiquer lancée
elle débouchera 8 mois plus tard le 6
avril dernier c'était sur une
proposition de loi discuter à l'occasion
de la niche parlementaire écologiste à
l'Assemblée et que proposer Julien
Bailly les services de transport aériens
non régulier de passagers ne faisant pas
l'objet d'une exploitation commerciale
ainsi que les services non réguliers de
transport aérien public dont le nombre
de passagers est inférieur à 60 voilà à
la tribune Julien Bayou a dénoncé
chiffres à l'appui l'augmentation de 55%
du nombre de vols en jet privé au départ
de la France qui ferait de notre pays le
numéro 1 des émissions de CO2 générés
par des jets privés dans l'Union
européenne tous ces chiffres claquent
ils sont vrais mais il y en a d'autres
aussi parce qu'il y a des raccourcis et
le député de Paris ne précise pas par
exemple que pour choquant qu'elle soit
l'utilisation de ces jeux de privés ne
présente quand même que 0,1% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
notre pays mais je vous le disais le
symbole est important de la même de
Julien Bayou il s'agit de ramener les
riches sur terre et le texte a été
rejeté oui car l'exécutif ne voulait pas
on entend parler même si de ce côté là
aussi on a eu droit à quelques looping
parce que dans un premier temps le
ministre des Transports Clément Beaune
lui se prononcer pour une régulation et
une taxation de l'aviation d'affaires ça
c'était l'été dernier mais mais conseil
des ministre de rentrer et là il se fait
taper sur les doigts par le Président de
la République en personne qui appelle
ces troupes à ne pas céder aux
tentations de la démagogie alors prudent
Clément bonne pendant la discussion du
projet de loi de finances proposera
d'augmenter de 70% la taxe sur les
carburants de l'aviation privée parce
que si elle n'existe pas dans la vision
civile il en existe une dans l'aviation
privée ça sera voté et puis l'ordre de
l'examen de la proposition de loi Bayou
en avril dernier alors là il va invoquer
toute une série d'arguments pour dire
que c'est pas faisable on va pas mettre
ça serait trop compliqué à contrôler
toutes les allers-retours de tous ces
jets on va pas mettre des agents
derrière tous ces vols privés et puis il
annonce quand même la contribue la
création d'une nouvelle contribution sur
sur l'aviation commerciale privée ça
c'est à voir ça serait éventuellement
dans la prochaine loi de finances celle
qui serait donc pour l'année 2024 et qui
sera disputé cet automne mais on en
parlait tout à l'heure cette fameuse
décision d'interdire les les vols
intérieurs quand il existe une
alternative de 2h30 en train une
première mondiale se félicite
aujourd'hui Clément baume dans son
communiqué au nom de la nécessaire
décarbonation de vie qui concerne les
donc les lignes aériennes intérieures
mais mais par les jeunes privées
évidemment
interdire les vols des jets privés les
les surtaxés Mireille c'est quoi c'est
de la récupération politique c'est un
combat justifié comment vous l'analysez
ça alors c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup
de l'ordre du symbole mais mais le
symbole est extrêmement important et on
l'a vu au moment de la crise des gilets
jaunes c'est à dire qu'il y a toute une
partie de la population qui est
convaincue et à juste titre que elle n'a
pas de moyen de de d'échapper
une fiscalité croissante et qui devrait
continuer à croître sur les carburants
alors que justement cette partie de des
missions n'est pas n'est pas taxée donc
donc je pense que il serait extrêmement
important de montrer que alors pour en
revenir à un sujet qui me préoccupe la
plupart du temps il serait très
important de relancer en fait la
trajectoire de la taxe carbone tout en
l'accompagnant à la fois de mesures de
redistribution vers les plus pauvres et
de mesure de taxation spécifiques et de
taxation progressive pour les plus
riches et pour ceux qui utilisent les
jets privés les jets privés devraient
être hyper surtaxés pour alors certains
vont nous dire ça ne va pas empêcher les
utilisateurs de jet de les de continuer
à le faire en revanche je suis quand
même persuadée tout le monde est
sensible à l'augmentation marginale du
d'un prix et ça limiterait les usages
mais quand même je vois vous entendre
là-dessus Béatrice j'arrive puisque
Mathieu vous donne le chiffre de 0,1%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans notre pays pour les jets privés si
on ramène ça au passager c'est à dire
que si alors évidemment ça va dépendre
du nombre de passagers dans un jet et de
ça mais vous avez j'imagine calculé ça
vous êtes très fort là-dedans
non j'imagine que c'est énorme oui c'est
énorme puisque les les avions
commerciaux sur lesquels sont calculés
les les valeurs usuelles employées
notamment par l'ADEME pour estimer les
émissions unitaires sont
17 ans de démission de guerre en
français vous y êtes favorable mesure
l'interdiction
toujours un petit peu difficile à
assumer on va dire la taxation ça sans
problème
je pense que
on est tous avis même si comme dit
Madame ça va peut-être pas changer les
comportements au moins symboliquement
c'est important qu'il soit intégrer 50%
de biocarburant dans le dans le
carburant des jet privé par exemple ça
ça rendrait le carburant beaucoup plus
cher pour finalement on a bien compris
que la filière n'existait pas et que et
qu'on avait pas assez de biocarburant
pour fournir tous ceux qui utilisent
relativement peu donc de toute façon il
deviendrait beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
propre
me disent qu'on parle de aussi
d'innovation parce qu'elle de Isaïe on
n'a pas du tout parlé de l'électrique
est-ce que il pourrait être adapté à des
petits avions comme ça des jets de de
place c'est vrai qu'au début il y avait
un débat électrique hydrogène on voit
bien que le mouvement de balancier est
en train de de basculer vers l'hydrogène
parce que l'électrique il y a le
problème du poids des batteries la
dimension etc et on voit que la piste
pour la décarbonation c'est plus
hydrogène mais de notre côté il faut pas
se faire des illusions non plus
l'hydrogène ça sera pas la panacée avant
très longtemps pour la décarbonation du
transport aérien parce que on voit bien
que l'hydrogène est horriblement cher
mais surtout il ne s'applique à des
petits avions donc ça ira pour des
avions privés peut-être un peu de
l'aviation régionale mais avant que
l'hydrogène qu'on ait trouvé la solution
technique pour l'appliquer à des avions
gros porteur non courrier il y en a pour
plusieurs décennies donc c'est pour ça
qu'il nous faut trouver d'autres moyens
de décarbonation dans les carburants
durables par exemple sur l'hydrogène
dernier témoignage que j'apporte au
débat justement sur les gros avions
puisque Airbus travaille sur sur un
appareil commercial zéro émission
hypothèse 2035 on va écouter le
directeur de l'ingénierie qui liste les
obstacles à franchir
plus le nombre d'industries qui
appelleront l'hydrogène sera grand plus
on pourra imager des coûts d'hydrogène
bas quelque chose qui est rare et
souvent cher donc l'hydrogène pour qu'il
soit rentable c'est un peu un cercle
vertueux il faut que toutes les
industries de la mobilité l'appel en
même temps et que les gouvernements et
une politique d'incitation à
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène bon alors
c'était pas exactement le l'extrait
qu'on avait choisi mais c'est pas très
grave il disait le volume 4 fois
supérieur au kérosène pour la même
quantité d'énergie la température il
faut le stocker à moins 153 degrés et
puis la modification des moteurs aussi
ça veut dire que si on imagine elle est
Airbus un avion hydrogène en 2035 c'est
un nouvel avion on peut pas adapter les
avions existants il faut plus de place
et donc ça ne s'appliquera pas même en
2035 comme je dis à des avions gros
porteurs long courrier donc voilà donc
on a pour des décennies encore avant de
trouver une solution et n'oubliez pas
c'est ce que je disais c'est que même si
cet avion existait en 2050 après que
j'aurai un processus de renouvellement
et de modernisation d'un parc de
dizaines de milliers d'avions et donc ça
si vous voulez ça ne pourra se faire que
progressivement c'est pas un autre tour
de main on va décider de remplacer tous
les avions par des avions à hydrogène
qui faudra produire il y aura des
cadences de production il faudra
financer les achats de ces avions qui
sont peut-être extrêmement onéreux et
peut-être plus onéreux que les avions
actuels donc c'est pour ça moi je crois
que si on veut être pragmatique et
concret bon il faut il y a toutes les
améliorations technologiques déjà des
avions des motoristes etc bon c'est pas
la solution à 100% mais déjà il y a des
améliorations et c'est vraiment les
carburants durables donc nous dans le
secteur aérien c'est pour ça on met un
focus très marqué sur l'inspecteur et
puis pour conclure sur l'hydrogène
Béatrice Jarry là aussi il faut le
produire et donc il faut de
l'électricité pour le produit et ça
dépend si l'électricité verte ou pas
enfin bon c'est pas si simple de
produire de tout à fait l'essentiel de
l'hydrogène actuellement sur terre est
produite de manière sale on va dire à
partir de
produits fossiles donc ça c'est pas
c'est évidemment pas cette hydrogène là
qu'on vise quand on parle de
décarbonation des avions et du reste de
l'économie de l'industrie aussi qui est
très industrie d'ailleurs quand qu'on
pourrait l'utiliser l'hydrogène c'est
sans doute le plus le plus naturel et le
plus efficace
donc prioritairement à notre sens dans
l'industrie en effet
et ailleurs
dans la dans l'aérien aussi mais à très
long terme comme comme évoqué par Pascal
du zagher merci beaucoup on a vu qu'il y
avait vraiment de voilà de de conception
de l'avenir de l'aviation qui qui se
confrontait sur ce plateau c'était très
intéressant merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission et tous les
programmes de la chaîne évidemment sur
notre plateforme Public Sénat point fr
dommage laisse les clés à Mathieu
croissanto les clés pas de camions les
clés de l'avion je vous souhaite une
belle émission demain avec la très belle
équipe de sens public et les équipes de
Xéna et puis
notez que la prochaine invité politique
demain dans la matinale cette année
genovar la députée LR du douké
secrétaire général des républicains
belle soirée